Let's go to your voicemails.
That two, one nine two David P we told a story
on the bonus show about children throwing
snowballs at cars and someone driving a car
shooting at the children.
And I guess I must have told a story about
my history with snowballs that confused some
people in the audience.
Take a listen to this.
Hi David.
Um, I heard you mentioned a story about, uh,
kids were being shot after throwing snowballs
at passing cars.
And you said that it reminded you of something
that you and producer Louis used to do.
And I'd like it if you could just clarify.
Were you saying that you and producer Lewis
used to throw snowballs at passing cars or
were you saying that you and producer Lewis
used to shoot people after they threw snowballs
at your car when you were driving?
Yeah, of course.
It's the latter.
You're Louis and I used to shoot at people
who would throw snowballs at our cars, obviously
that's what I meant.
Okay.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
The Tennessee governor says he will sign an
anti gay adoption bill.
It's 2020 folks.
It's 2020 and this is still going on.
We're going to talk about that.
Matt Gates, one of the most extreme and vial
Republican members of Congress is in a weird
Twitter battle with a Florida house Republican,
and I want to talk about it and I want to
dig into Matt Gates history a little bit,
and also chief justice Roberts is weighing
in on whether the new catchphrase, okay, boomer
is a form of age discrimination riveting.
Of course, we want to know what chief justice
Roberts thinks about that.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show, get [inaudible]
then access by signing up@joinpacmandotcomorbybecomingapatronatthefivedollaramonthlevelatpatrion.com
slash David package, the
David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].